well the new venture aims to help people
navigate through fake news on social
media
a recent study reveals nearly half of
adults in the u.s. sometimes are often
used social media as a new source but
both Facebook and Twitter acknowledged
that Russian propaganda reached more
than 126 million Americans through their
platforms around the 2016 election news
guard technologies is a new six million
dollar venture that will launch this
fall to battle so-called fake news the
startup will use an owl analyst to
research and rate thousands of news
sources they hope to license their
finding to social media companies and
other platforms news Gard technologies
co-founder Steven Brill is an author
journalist entrepreneur welcome Steve
thanks for being mornings so tell us how
this is going to work well we're going
to apply common sense to a problem that
the algorithms haven't been able to
solve we're gonna hire dozens of
journalists to read and review the 7,500
news and information sites that are
responsible for 98 percent of the
consumption in the United States and
it's gonna be very simple they're gonna
be charged with telling the difference
between the Denver Post which is a real
newspaper and the Denver Guardian which
is a hoax site and what will people get
once these reporters look at these there
are those red green or yellow right oh
they'll see a red green and yellow and
if they mouse over that they'll see a 2
or 300 word description called a
nutrition label that will tell them the
background of the publication who owns
it what their history is are they
responsible who's behind it how do they
complain if they have a complaint about
something on the other hand if the news
site is Leste an information thing about
you know fracking and it's financed by
the American Petroleum Institute they'll
see that too and that'll probably be a
yellow it's a great idea Steve because
sometimes when you're online if you
don't know what really is hard to tell
the difference but don't you have to
have the cooperation of Facebook Twitter
and some of these online sites they're
about a half a dozen of them
that we that we think will want to
license the data plus the advertising
agencies will want a license it so they
can keep their ads off of the fake sites
and what we're asking them in terms of
licensing fees is a fraction of what
they're paying their PR firms and their
lawyers to talk about how hard the
problem is to solve do most of them seem
interested quite interested yes you know
Facebook did this but in Reverse for
their what's trending half they had
people initially going through it right
and then they were accused of being
biased and then they turn to algorithms
which got us to where we are now how are
you going to avoid being accused of bias
well first of all when Facebook dear
they didn't tell you who the people were
we will list the backgrounds and the
names of everybody doing every review we
will take all kinds of complaints the
complaints will be public will have an
appeal system and probably equally
important what we're doing is not quite
as presumptuous is that we're saying
there is a real difference between the
Denver Guardian which is a fake site and
the Denver Post and if the Denver
Guardian wants to game our algorithm
which is in an algorithm they just have
to start doing real news and be
accountable for it and tell people who
they are Steve how do you want to be
gamed how do you manage the difference
between ideological reporting and
straight-up reporting because some as
you know I think come with an
ideological bent can report the Dickens
out of a story and get it right but
they're still coming at it with an
ideological that's where the nutrition
labels come in there's obviously a
difference between the Nation magazine
and and the National Review but they're
both you know legitimate news
organizations who try to get it right
they just come at it from a different
perspective if you click on the
nutrition label for each you will see
exactly that in their own words what
they say their missions are president
Trump uses the term fake news very
liberally some people say uses that term
when it's an unflattering story about
him or his administration how do you
define fake news something that is
deliberately aimed at defrauding you
it's
hoax or it's a you know propaganda from
the Russian government this comes in an
era of extreme tribalism people sticking
with their own silos are you concerned
at all that people may want to continue
that trend that they may not be
interested in knowing what's real and
what's not they want to stick with what
their their current source of
information if it's feeding them the
news they want to hear that comes under
the category of us nology that we are
going to not solve all the problems of
the world you know in a world in which
you know a certain percentage of people
think you know that 9/11 was an inside
job by the Bush administration and
another percentage think that you know
the president the President Obama was
not born in the United States we're not
going to satisfy everybody but we are
going to equip people to understand the
basics behind the headlines that they're
seeing on their searches and on their
feeds
thank you for beginning to address this
issue I know you've raised some six
million dollars thus far best of luck
thanks tempers thank you we appreciate
preacher cbsn it's what kind of reading
I wouldn't dare common anybody's reading
a plus in Army as I say in Braille
that's not fake with no bias yes